[Applause]
[Music]
it's just a few short days till August
which means new releases is taking
another look at the entire month ahead
August has a good batch of minigames
sports games and big expansions to
existing games I hope you're not tired
of hearing the word games yet let's dive
into some of the biggest ones launching
this month we're actually going to start
off with handhelds because WarioWare
gold is all about mixing things up gold
brings together micro games from the
whole Wario Ware series and adds a few
new ones for a total of 300 micro games
for you to enjoy that's the most in
anyone game by far and gold is also the
first one to feature full voice acting
that's pretty Wario where gold is
already playable on 3ds in some
territories but it's coming stateside on
Friday August 3rd and you can grab the
eShop demo right now if you don't want
to wait since we're talking about the
States let me just say that there's also
a new madden on the way madden 19 is the
first one in 10 years to let you do
touchdown dances since they were made
legal in the NFL again just a few years
ago it also sports new real player
motions which means more realistic
movement on the field long shot story
mode is back and Ultimate Team mode is
getting new three-on-three matches and a
leaderboard with rewards that's all
happening on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Friday August 10th and now a little
something for the MMO crowd well I guess
little isn't the right word because
World of Warcraft battle for Azeroth
expansion is a big deal this one bumps
the level cap to 120 and adds two whole
new continents plus more dungeons raids
playable races and uncharted islands to
explore that's coming to PC on Tuesday
August 14th I know it's an old meme but
I really hope someone recreates Wyles
most iconic moment in one of the new
dungeons
speaking of old things
Shenmue 1 and 2 were coming back it's
important to note that these are not
remasters but they do come with new
features like modern and classic
controls and updated UI scalable
resolution in both English and Japanese
voiceovers if you've never experienced
the adventure of Ryo Hazuki you can grab
both games for 30 bucks on ps4 Xbox one
or PC on Tuesday August 21st let's
finish up with another Japanese game
making a big comeback Yokosuka wha me
too is getting a worldwide release so if
you've never taken Kazuma Kiryu for a
spin in the original Yakuza 2 now's your
chance to do it with new gameplay
enhancements and cutscenes that iron out
the wrinkles of this story there's even
a whole new scenario starring secondary
protagonists goro majima that's all
happening on ps4 on Tuesday August 28th
and if you want to take the story even
further back you can also grab the PC
port of Yakuza 0 on the first day of the
month and those are some of the hottest
games we'll be playing all month long as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with a more
focused group of August games next
Sunday
you